رواد السوشيال ميديا يتفاعلون مع فوز
مانشستر سيتي غاريث بيل يتالق في
كاليفورنيا وانتقادات عديده لشعار كاس
العالم المقبله هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها
لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
تفاعل رواد السوشيال ميديا مع الفوز
الكبير الذي حققه مانشستر سيتي امام ريال
مدريد وبلوغه نهائي دوري الابطال للمره
الثانيه في ثلاث سنوات جماهير نادي
الاسباني انتقدت على مختلف صفحات الرياضيه
مدرب فريق كارلو انشيلوتي واثنت في الوقت
ذاته على اداره غوارديولا للمباراه وهو
الذي يملك فرصه لا تعوض ليكون اول مدرب
يفوز بالثلاثيه التاريخيه مرتين ومع
فريقين مختلفين
صحيفه ليكيب المعروفه بتقييمها الصارم
منحت نجمي ريال مدريد وبنزيما ثلاثه من
عشره وهو التقييم ذاته الذين له رودريغو
فالفيردي وايضا كمافينجا في المقابل تلقى
برناردو سيلفا التقييم الاعلى بثمانيه من
عشره ومعه ايضا الالماني كوندوغان والظهير
كي ووكر بعد تمكنه من ايقاف خطوره
فينيسيوس جونيور
وبعيدا عن اوروبا ومباريات الحماسيه
يستمتع غاريث بيل بلعب الجولف في ولايه
الكاليفورنيا الامريكيه بيل يبدو انه
احترف فعلا لعب الجولف بعدما تمكن من
الفوز بنقطه من المحاوله الاولى وهو امر
لا ينجح في فعله سوى نجوم اللعبه وفرحه
احراز لقب في عالم كره القدم
كشفت اللجنه المنظمه لكاس العالم
2026 عن شعار البطوله التي ستستضيفها
الولايات المتحده مع كندا والمكسيك الشعار
تلقى انتقادات كبيره على السوشيال ميديا
حيث قال بعض المتابعين بان مده تصميمه لم
تتجاوز دقيقه واحده وجرت العاده ان يمثل
اشعار نسخه ثقافه البلد المستضيف لكن شعر
النسخه المقبله ضمه فقط رقم 26 وصوره لكاس
العالم